vas-y c'est le plus grand vol de
l'histoire
TF1 arrêtez le match what the fuck mais
c'est fou
et sur TF1 il y a la pub
non mais c'est fou c'est le multivers là
c'est du jamais vu
sur TF1 le match s'est arrêté et là ça
continue sur BeIn Sport c'est improbable
alors TF1 a dû faire un communiqué il
faut me faire que des communiqués en ce
moment
chers téléspectateurs après la remise en
jeu des Tunisiens et que l'arbitre a
sifflé la fin du match nous avons comme
pour tous les matchs rendu l'antenne
pour laisser la place au mag ça sert à
rien le bac
retransmettez le match c'est tout ce
qu'on vous demande pendant ce laps de
temps un arbitrage vidéo a été demandé
et le but tricolore refusé cette
séquence a fait l'ouverture du mag nous
sommes vraiment désolé pour ceux qui
n'ont pas pu vivre ce moment en direct
[Rires]
il vaut mieux ne rien faire plutôt que
de dire ça mais vous savez que dans la
foulée en top tweet immédiatement et
monter le hashtag mais TF1 météo
égalisation à la 99e minute TF1 lancé
quatre mariages pour une lune de miel je
suis en larmes on est vraiment pas un
pays de foot
pour le moment de légende sur TF1 le
match se joue encore alors qu'on est
devant le Camping Paradis TF1 qui arrête
de diffuser alors que le but est refusé
ptdr les tarés des gens font la fête en
France en pensant qu'on a égalisé vous
avez du sang sur les ventes
lui il est parti
c'est incroyable c'est une erreur
historique enfin c'est TF1 qui a acheté
ah bon avec bean ils ont les mâles de
l'équipe de France et grande fête
populaire des millions de je regarde des
troubles moyens de faire ça mais c'est
du jamais vu quoi couper une compétition
sportive c'est le direct c'est l'émotion
et là il nous casse tout non mais c'est
impossible déjà que leur diffusion c'est
moyen le mag très moyen franchement là
c'est c'est incroyable j'espère qu'il y
aura des sanctions parce que celui je
vais prévenir l'arc comme ça exactement
sur la vie de ma mère que saisie la
reconnais celui qui a pris cette
décision c'est un incapable moi je suis
dit que oui et l'image elle est terrible
pour TF1 parce qu'ils disent qu'ils ont
mis le mag mais ce qu'on voit on le voit
bien sur le monsieur et c'est que c'est
de la publicité exactement donc là on a
vraiment les deux images c'est une image
terrible pour toi
qui veulent pas que les gens décrochent
qui balancent partout on aimerait qu'il
fasse une interview ou deux à la fin du
match c'est une traite des cas comme ça
parce que c'est vraiment ça c'est
exceptionnel pour coup un but qui remet
en jeu après la fin c'est déjà arrivé
en tant que homme de télé comment vous
expliquer ça
comme télé je vais tuer je résumer ça
très vite l'oseille est plus important
que la diffusion il y a la pub qui va
arriver de d'un joueur qui ont rien à
[ __ ] ils sont des balancer vite la pub
l'interview tu penses que je t'explique
en fait à la fin des matchs
la courbe d'audience ça chute en une
minute
vertigineux ça veut dire que tu passes
de 10 millions de téléspectateurs à 2
millions tu perds 8 millions de
personnes donc plus il lance la vie la
pub vite le premier spot oui cher
puisque les gens restent encore devant
la pub enfin ils essaient de les
accrocher donc ils essaient d'envoyer le
plus vite possible donc là forcément ils
sont partis trop vite et Benjamin
connaissant
pour eux
on a encore une séquence de TF1
dans le Mac de la Coupe du monde ils ont
diffusé le sketch d'un humoriste qui
double les voix des joueurs de foot et
beaucoup de téléspectateurs aussi leur
sont tombés dessus ils sont fait
défoncer sur les réseaux voilà donc là
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
c'est pas de ma faute
regardez on vous a diffusé l'extrait
dans la longueur
parce qu'il fallait que vous compreniez
bien le délire regarde cette deuxième
journée le Brésil grand favori affronter
une Suisse confiée tu sais qui c'est le
Brésil ou pas mais moi je veux pas finir
dans une vidéo moi je te dis qu'ils sont
prenables sur la route ma mère les gars
on attaque
et OK
c'est quoi cette histoire de défense
d'accord
comprends pas c'est quand on fait petit
pain alors registre de la régie ouais
Michel ah il se passe quoi avec les
lumières il a pété un plomb OK et voilà
pas les lumières ouais bah c'est pas des
lumières moi je te le dis l'absence de
Neymar laissez de la place à de jeunes
joueurs
tu croises les oreilles du lapin non du
lapin voilà comme ça et après tu fais
une boucle bon tu prends les deux
oreilles du lapin et tu lui fais un
petit pont c'est finalement Casimiro qui
offrit la victoire au Brésil d'une
frappe surpuissante elle est pas si
forte que ça bref regarde la même
d'oublier avec la fesse
de Roberto Carlos tu finis avec le bout
comme ça je me souviens une fois le
gardien
comme ça
quand même de tenter des choses après
voilà alors ce qui est énervé les
internautes parce que c'est que Julien
Cazarre à l'époque sur Canal+ on faisait
j'ai plus ses règles pas mal c'est drôle
qu'est-ce qu'il y a jamais vu un beau
gosse un beau mec avec un beau chapeau
un beau manteau [ __ ] qu'est-ce que je
me kiffe vas-y casse-toi si tu as envie
hein [ __ ] je suis beau je me kiffe
trop j'ai un bon plan là thunderland on
est payé pareil mais on joue à 15e place
non tu déconnes ouais je te jure appelle
les autres ok eh les gars on est en
plein thunderland venez voir oh bien on
arrive on arrive
bah ils sont où les cons Willy
la bande de blaireau là avec taverno les
a vendu 70 millions à des Américains mon
pote non
voilà
donc c'est vrai que ça a été si on fait
défoncer les pots oui non mais les
bonnes idées elles sont faites pour être
piquées mais il faut bien les piqués le
problème c'est que ça franchement c'est
une super idée faire parler les joueurs
et tout mais faut être super drôle là
c'était d'une tristesse c'est ça c'est
une intervention que vous auriez pu
faire dans le 6 à 7